du coup tu te mets en fait moi je le
connais mal le générique
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour un nouvel épisode de l'amour est
nécessaire ou nous allons tenter de
répondre à une question cruciale et
essentielle et qui fait débat dans le
monde de la science depuis des décennies
y at il un lien entre indiana jones et
l'archéologie
autrement dit indiana jones est il un
archéologue
nous non on va développer un peu parce
que sinon ils n'auraient pas d'épisode
cette question est sans doute celle qui
m'a été le plus souvent posée car ce
film c'est film puisqu'il y en a quatre
ont fait naître chez certains la
vocation de devenir archéologue
alors c'est parti pour un décryptage
archéologique de ce chef-d'oeuvre du
septième art tu imites dès à présent
indiana jones n'a rien un archéologue
c'est au mieux un chasseur de trésors à
la mode 19e siècle ok mais pourquoi
qu'est ce qui ne fonctionne pas d'un
point de vue historique
alors évidemment on pourrait s'arrêter à
sa tenue vestimentaire et à ses
accessoires
il faudrait échanger son fouet contre
une truelle et ses chaussures de villes
contre des chaussures de sécurité
mais passons ensuite son attitude notre
quand même chez lui ou tendance à
détruire tout ce qui l'entouré en
particulier ce qui est précieux et
anciens et que je grimpe sur une statue
égyptienne et que je fait s'effondrer un
temple antique etc etc
en somme l' inverse du bureau
d'archéologues qui consiste à conserver
les vestiges à faire preuve de minutie
et de concentration ou le monde
tesson poterie est scellée sous
plastique avec un moment spécial puis
envoyées directement en laboratoire bon
vous avez saisi l'idée je pense mais à
part ces soucis de mise en scène ses
films pose de réels problèmes aux
archéologues pour ou différentes trois
ans que je vais donc vous expliquer
d'abord le premier point dérangeantes
c'est la vision qui est donné de l'autre
l'étranger du sauvage un monde sauvage
on ne se trouve d'ailleurs les vestiges
archéologiques qui n'a pas des espaces
temps on ne sait jamais où se passe
l'action on est wagon dans la jungle
et on n'a pas non plus l'idée de quand
date précisément les objets antiques et
c'est un parti pris qui va à l'encontre
de l'archéologie
ensuite la plupart des décors vous vous
présente ne sont pas réalistes
c'est à dire qu'il n'est même pas
possible techniquement qu'ils aient pu
exister
c'est le cas de cette salle couvert
d'une coupole l'action est supposé se
dérouler dans un temple de l'egypte
antique
or la coupole n'existe pas à cette
époque nous serons à noter que quelques
millénaires plus tard par les romains la
première coupole connu provient de la
domus aurea à rome
autrement dit les palais de l'empereur
néron construire 65 après jésus-christ
pour les objets c'est pareil cette
statue est par exemple est un mélange
d'inspirations me mayan égyptienne
difficile à dire ce qui est sûr c'est
que vous aurez beau visiter tous les
musées du monde
vous le trouverez jamais rien de
ressemblant après tout toutes ces
incohérences c'est pas très grave
puisqu'il s'agit d'une fiction mais quel
est le rapport entre ce film d'action et
l'archéologie au furet ce vraiment un
film sur l'archéologie
prenons le premier film de la série les
aventuriers de l'arche perdue qui date
de 1981 réalisé par spielberg et qui
détient à mon sens toutes les clés pour
répondre à ces questions et comprendre
la façon dont est traitée l'archéologie
en fiction résumons rapidement film on
né en 1936 et indiana jones
après un voyage en amérique du sud à la
recherche d'une statuette en or est
envoyé par les services secrets
américains
au caire où se déroulent des fouilles
dirigées par les nazis les nazis cherche
l'arche d'alliance qui contiendrait les
tables de la loi qu'il faut retenir
c'est que ces objets sont des reliques
qui détiennent pense des pouvoirs
magiques
malgré toutes les critiques qu'on peut y
faire ce film présente un intérêt
historique à propos des nazis justement
j'aime venir en partie de l'intrigué
tourne autour des équipes d'archéologues
nazis envoyé au caire et bien ça c'est
un fait très important dans l'histoire
du 20e siècle que nous explique ce
passage qui est selon moi le plus
intéressant du film the thing is not the
same aux états unis indiana et tout
juste rentré de son périple en amérique
du sud et donne des cours d'archéologie
à la fac
ces deux hommes l'un des services
secrets américains expliquent à indiana
jones
l'objet des recherches effectuées au
caire par les nazis retrouver l'arche
d'alliance sans avoir de réelles
explications sur les raisons qui
poussent les nazis
à sa découverte indiana leur explique
tout l'enjeu idéologique qui se cacher
ces fouilles et s'étonne que ces deux
agents n'est pas plus de souvenirs du
récit biblique et du rôle de l'arche
d'alliance dans sa question rhétorique
de l'audition
vous séchez catéchisme ce que dit ce
personnage est tout à fait vrai ou
pierre était réellement obsédé par les
objets antiques les règles des croix
gammées sont des symboles hérité
d'antiquités à partir de 1938 les nazis
cherche des validations et leur
idéologie dans les vestiges historiques
hitler lancent des campagnes de fouille
un peu partout en europe qui vise à
ramener en allemagne véronique ce sont
des objets et doit appartenir simple qui
son sac sous le régime nazi il veut
rattacher son idéologie raciale a des
origines glorieuse des recherches
obstinément les objets mythiques
le problème c'est qu'en allemagne il
faut marquer au il n'y a pas grand chose
à part des vestiges préhistoriques ou
protohistorique sterna du bronze là je
vais faire en italie là où les vestiges
romains sont les mieux conservées
mussolini a déjà procédé à cette
récupération pour son propre compte
il a fait fouiller la zone du forum
mêmes principes en avant via des fori
imperiali qui relie sa résidence privée
palladio venezzia au colisée c'est un
sujet passionnant semé de l'archéologie
glazik a choisi traité spielberg sujet
d'autant plus originale qu'il est
rarement évoquée dans le cinéma pour les
nazis on s'attache le plus souvent aux
camps de concentration au conflit pour
cela le film est juste et présentent un
intérêt historique
je vous ai dit juste avant que je
considérais cet extrait comme le plus
important du film car en regardant
attentivement cette séquence on tout
autre lecture du film est possible alors
ce n'est que ma vision que je vous livre
ici et vous aviez en commentaires sont
les bienvenus
mais selon moi indiana jones et les
aventuriers de l'arche perdue n'est pas
un film sur l'archéologie
ce n'est pas non plus un film sur un
archéologue ces rudes trésor salut tout
un film sur la bible et c'est même un
cours de catéchisme
pourquoi parce qu'il a d'abord cette
phrase que d' indiana ou de type des
services secrets vous séchez le
catéchisme elle est lourde de sens de
cette phrase l ai pas dit devant
n'importe qui deux représentants de
l'état par un prof de fac
la hiérarchie est complètement inversé
ici et puis regardez où l'on se trouve
comment est la pièce tout en longueur
pas une salle de classe classique comme
on peut en voir installant dans le film
c'est pas non plus un amphithéâtre les
fenêtres sont très hautes et aaron
10 avec des vitres on est à
l'arrière-plan il ya des rangées de
chaises on se croirait dans une église
pour rappel spielberg a grandi dans une
famille croyante et pratiquante la
religion et donc d'un prisme de lecture
du monde au discours religieux
d'ailleurs porté par beaucoup de films
hollywoodiens est très présent aux états
unis de manière générale pas étonnant
donc qu'on retrouve des thèmes bibliques
sur le bien le mal et la fin des temps
autre élément qui vient vraiment appuyer
cette idée c'est le tableau pendant
toute la séquence le plan est assez
large
walt tableau dans sa totalité et l'ombre
des indiana bien balayer les écritures
fait à la craie ça tombe n'est pas
naturel voudrait bien qu'ils ont ajouté
un projet spécialement pour cet effet et
vous allez voir que c'est une annonce de
ce qui va suivre
mais avant ça roman à ce qui est écrit
sur le tableau qu'est ce qu'on voit on
voit des chiffres des signes d'addition
de multiplication des fractions des
racines carrées bref des calculs qui
symbolise l'écriture scientifique et
l'écriture scientifique c'est par
essence l'écriture de la vérité du moins
de la recherche
bien qu est ce qu ils ont fait une ghana
john de cette écriture scientifique
il la menace qu il retourne le tableau
est bien dessiné sur l'autre face son
interprétation religieuse des faits et
là vous avez le véritable but du fils
qui vous ai dit et qui vous est même
dessiné et la séquence est un mythe par
ce plan ouverture d'un livre avec la
présentation en gros plan d'un texte non
pas scientifique cette fois les
religieux la bible qu'alain générique de
début ce plan nous fait comprendre que
tout ce qui s'est passé avant n'a plus
cours et que c'est bien de religion on
va parler de films peints d'archéologie
moralité indiana jones n'est pas un
archéologue mais plutôt un genre de
missionnaires fétichiste
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai vraiment compris le film